fond saint denis selon cette équipe
l'envol denis vient est en train de
s'éteindre une commune fantôme
précise-t-on du de la population jeu une
équipe 15 personnes en campagne pour les
municipales de 2020 en fait 15 ans et
denis présente un potentiel
annie commis et sans étiquette est tête
de liste
surnommé getty 48 ans ingénieur en
développement du territoire
fonctionnaires de la ctm fille
d'agriculteur elle veut réveiller la
commune face il n'y a quand même des
ressources de ponte ancien qui
aujourd'hui je dirais est quelque peu
inexploité donc l'objectif en tous les
cas son regard de toutes ces compétences
que j'ai acquises de voir comment
valoriser ces ressources comment
valoriser ce potentiel que pour cette
crise nous on ça va se passer comment
cette campagne
électorale cette campagne électorale je
ne vais pas trop vous en dira pourquoi
parce que on va proposer une autre forme
de campagne que ceux que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
je garde le secret pour les stars font
saint denis un peu plus de 700 habitants
et près de 780 votants il ya beaucoup de
fausses de personnes de denise hier qui
ne réside pas sur la commune qui fait
que au moment du recensement ils ne sont
pas recensés sur la commune mais qui
ayant pour x raisons une attache que ce
soit un bien foncier qui sont votants
sur la commune
ils ont toujours voté sur la commune et
par ailleurs une commune tournée vers
l'agriculture l'artisanat une école une
église en travaux et la fête patronale
c'est ce week-end l'occasion à coup sûr
de faire passer ses idées